hello my name is malia i'm 12 years old
and i
am a contestant on this season of
masterchef junior and i'm katie i'm a tc
producer and i am
much older uh so today we are going to
be competing to see who can make the
best dish
should we look over these rules yeah
rule number one
we must make a dessert rule number two
the dessert must be something that you
would serve at a fancy dinner party
i love dinner party are you throwing
dinner parties all the time i mean
sometimes i gotta
just go to them you're very cool and
rule number three the star ingredient
must be
chocolate are you ready for this yes
let's do this oh
wow okay let's do it let's yes i don't
have a
huge culinary background i would say
like i'm a self-taught home cook
i was around three or four years old
when i started
helping out in the kitchen baking and
cooking
they're just in my comfort zone look
i'm terrified of this kid she's been on
masterchef junior okay
i love katie she's super sweet super
nice
i think she just might be a little
nervous but that's okay
we all get nervous but i do have the
home court advantage because we're in
the tasty kitchen
i know my way around i know the gear and
i feel safe here
when i'm in competition i keep calm and
i've always had that little voice in my
head that says
you could do it you could do it you
could do it and if i don't make it
at least i try my hardest okay so we're
ready to get started
you also have a very cool jacket i have
a black apron but yeah so what are you
making so i'm making a chocolate souffle
with a raspberry coulis and a dollop of
whipped cream
i'm making a chocolate dark chocolate
caramel tart with a chocolate cookie
crust and a little
sea salt to go on the top but that's
fancy thank you
okay well before we get in let's wish
each other good luck do you want to
shake or do you want to
oh my gosh okay let's hug that you're
awesome okay good luck
my first step is i'm gonna make my crust
i'm gonna food process these cookies so
that they get ground down like a sand
texture
to make my tart crust what are you doing
my first step is i'm just taking my
ramekins and i'm buttering them
and then i'm sprinkling it with some
sugar so how often have you made
this souffle before it's not like my
strongest soup but
i feel like yeah you got to live life
yes you've got to live life now that
these are done i'm going to go put them
in the fridge so they could show
i think you're feeding me already i'm
taking this vanilla bean and i'm
scraping out the vanilla bean pods
putting this in the pot and then adding
my whole milk so that could simmer
so now that my crust is done i'm going
to prepare my tart pans
i just want to make sure that we have
the right proportion of crust
too not too thick not too thin you know
what i mean slow and steady
slow and steady i'm dumping my sugar
and my flour into a bowl then i'm going
to add my three egg yolks
after that's done i'm going to gradually
put this
in and whisk once you come in you just
gotta cut it
good well while you do that i'm gonna go
bake these all right good luck thank you
so now i'm just going to put this back
in the pot and i'm going to let it boil
for one to two minutes i think malia is
doing awesome she's got
lots of burners going and i'm very
impressed
i think that the flavoring and the
texture is going to be
a winning combination so now i'm just
taking my thick dough
out and now i'm just going to add my
dark chocolate into my
double boiler and i'm just trying to
have the smell as soon as possible so
then i could just put the chocolate
into here and then i seal it tightly
yeah it's good so i'm gonna make my
ganache now and i'm just gonna heat up
some heavy cream and put it with some
dark chocolate and as you can see
it's really melting all the chocolate
thickening up here
i'm gonna go check on my crust and i'll
keep coming back
as long as katie's not here
good we are just putting this
into here and now we're just going to
did you miss me
yes okay well my crusts are done if you
wanted to know
cool i'm gonna pour my ganache now so
malia what do you want to be when you
grow up
all right do
tell me let's dig in a lawyer
or a nurse both of those are so good and
i want to be a critical care nurse
that's going to be intense yeah that's
going to be are you ready
i'm ready like if i trust fold right now
you catch me okay ready
no you'll be great if i was in critical
care i would want you
at the door being like hello here's a
souffle and a big needle
and a big needle that's right you can do
it all my i believe in you
i'm just gonna keep producing tasty
videos
i'm gonna go put this in the fridge i
might even
put it in our like strong freezer just
to speed this time up
and now just went in my pot we have the
raspberries
sugar and lemon juice and just for a
little kick we are going to add some
shampoo are you allowed to drink that
that's alcohol right breaks down okay
i'm gonna start making my caramel it's
brown sugar
we're gonna do some butter and when i
say some i mean a lot of butter
we're gonna do some light corn syrup and
then i'm gonna add some heavy cream
and then we're gonna add some salt what
i am worried about is that this won't
set in time for the judging
so it's okay it's okay thank you so
you're making whipped cream
yes i'm pouring my heavy cream
so just get started and fluffy then i
add my powdered sugar
i'm just going to add it half because i
don't want it to like
because i've had that happen before
let's add the rest and slowly
so now i'm gonna go put this in the
fridge
so my caramel's really it's starting to
boil right now
and i'm back did you miss me i'm yes i
mean it
now i'm just gonna grab a bowl and a
strainer ooh
okay cause this is like kind of like a
compost or like a puree
that you're gonna like put over it and i
guess like this is also a way to make
jam
my mom makes really good we have a
pomegranate tree in our
growing up but i wasn't allowed to eat
pomegranates inside the house because
they stain everything you know so i had
to eat it with a bib outside
can can i try some too
[Music]
well yeah i'm feeling intimidated you
should be no i'm just kidding
now i'm going to do my egg whites
so it's nice and fluffy are you doing an
accent right now
and we're like so oh my god are we
british
and when it has soft peaks i'm going to
add my fine sugar
oh it is getting really fluffy yes so
how you can test caramel is you can take
some and put it in a
cold bowl of water and then you can see
if it balls
up and you kind of kind of know if
you're close or not and i
am not close so i just gotta wait a few
more minutes now that this chocolate
base is back
from the fridge i'm just going to add my
fluffy egg whites a third of it is going
to go in we're not going to fold this
one because we want to get a little bit
of texture
oh i put my ganache in the freezer and
it got really hard but i think that's to
be okay because i'm about to put hot
caramel on it so
here we go oh god
okay we're just gonna slow this one down
okay
i'm gonna just now do my seat salt i
like got a little excited
and now it's a little bit more set i'm
gonna do that on this guy
now all i have to do is go put them in
the oven okay great all right i'll be
back okay
i'm gonna hang out and eat some caramel
and some cookies
[Music]
so next i'm gonna take these tarts out
of their pans and put them on a plate i
have melted some chocolate and i am
using a piping bag just to do like
a nice little drizzle across the top all
in all still falling pretty good
i still feel like i could win this thing
so my souffles just came out of the oven
i'm just going to put dollops of whipped
cream on the outer side of the plate
jersey the plate
with raspberry cooley take my powdered
sugar and i'm just going to sift it sift
to sift it then a raspberry on top
i do think i'm gonna win i wish for the
best of luck
but later skater i'm jen harris and i'm
a senior food writer for the los angeles
times today i'm going to be judging the
dishes that katie and malia made
nobody told me jen harris was going to
be judging this competition she's tried
all the food she knows all the chefs
she's written about tons of restaurants
i think jen would really like my food
because i try to cook for my culture
and my heart for me what makes a good
chocolate dessert is something craveable
it has to have like good chocolate
flavor but i also like a little bit of
salt a little bit of sour
something to balance out all that heavy
chocolate i'm going to be looking at
plating
does it look like something that would
be at a fancy dinner party does it look
like something i'd want to pay
a good amount of money for i really have
no idea who's going to win
hey jen thank you for coming to judge
today thanks for having me
we're not going to tell you who made
what dish are you excited
yes i'm a little excited yeah i'm a
little nervous meet you but we're fine
be nervous i'm just super tough okay
i'm gonna start with this one that is
beautiful
i already like the plating see it's
supposed to be a souffle
it has fallen a little bit it is not
exactly as high as i would like it
still warm though texture is really good
it's super light nice and cakey there's
like a little bit of crust across the
top
let me get a little bit of this sauce on
there
mmm this souffle is pretty fancy i feel
like if i went to a five-star restaurant
and i ordered this for dessert i'd be
really happy
a little disappointed that the souffle
fell but in terms of flavor and texture
the chocolate flavor
is like a really nice punch of chocolate
balance that with that like
cool raspberry coulis very impressed
with this dessert number two
oh so kudos on the plating i like that
little
drizzle of chocolate on there i think it
is a
caramel tart of sorts
i like the crispy crunch of the crust
already
this is also very good good level of
sweetness
i love the flake sea salt on top you
very much taste the caramel so you can't
really taste the chocolate it's getting
a little lost
but i would definitely eat this entire
thing still both of these desserts were
super fancy
i would be happy with either of them but
i was told i have to pick a winner so
i'm going to pick one
and the winner is the chocolate souffle
who is the chocolate souffle oh my gosh
good job
thank you i had faith thank you thank
you
yours was very good too but this is the
clear winner oh my god
i won i lost
it's okay winning is not everything
i'm like pretty sad i think jen made the
right choice
my advice for katie is a little caramel
goes a long way
today i learned that like losing can
still be fun because i had such a fun
time cooking with malia like she's just
so cool
and i still feel good about my dish so i
just feel like i've learned to have
a more positive attitude i love this day
it was
super fun i got to meet katie
i feel like i'm accomplished
i would definitely rematch malia just
because i could like hang out with her
more because i really like hanging out
but also because i want to win
[Music]
you